hi everyone my name is olimir I'm a last
year PhD student in Tel Aviv University
and this is Joint work with my advisor
Professor Otto marshman who is Professor
of Chavez and a master's student Yuval
volkov and all of us from Tel Aviv
University
today I'm going to talk about the
resilience of free majority Dynamics to
non-uniform schedulers
so that line of the talk we're going to
talk about discrete crns we're going to
explore the notion of schedulers and
what have been used before
later on we're going to Define
specifically the free majority Dynamics
which is our static case and talk about
some new results and what we defined and
found out in our study
okay so discrete crns crn stands for
chemical reaction networks and we have
an anonymous agents and we can think of
each of them as kind of an automaton and
each agent holds a state from Q so let's
say for example Q can be true or false
and we have a multi-agent transition
function so the transitions occurring
multiple agents maybe from pairs of
states to pairs of States
um
um plays a role because we only care
about the states not the agents that
interact it against anonymity uh appears
when we summarize the status of the
network at each given time by a
configuration that only cares about how
many agents are in each state not which
agents but how many agents are in each
state so for example if we have this
network we the configuration would only
say well we have free false and four
truths nothing more
and the computation is done in round so
iteratively agents are chosen to
interact looking at those agents we only
care about so it's a current
um the current states that they have and
then we apply the transition function to
this set of states to get a new set of
states and this might also affect the
configuration at large so it's a count
of how many states exist in the network
from each possible state
and how can we compute a function
in this model well first of all we need
we have n inputs for each agent each
agent holds an input and we have a map
from the inputs to States and once every
agent mapped his input to a state we
have the initial configuration c0
and then we just run the protocol so we
run more and more interactions each
interaction we had transition function
which changes the configuration and we
have a sequence of configuration C1 C2
C3 and so on and so forth
and this stops when we reach a stable
configuration or perhaps a potentially
stable set of configurations that we're
not going to escape
and such a configuration or set of
configuration will be mapped to an
output and once we can map to an output
this means the computation is that
great so let's do an example
so we have the states true and false and
maybe we have the the transitions it
takes two false and keeps in two false
but if any of the two agents have a true
or both of them then they both will
switch to true so this is kind of or
between two agents and this can be used
to calculate the orb between the entire
set of Agents
um so let's see how it's done so we have
the configuration here is free false and
four true and of course if initially we
have at least one truth and we want all
of the agents to switch to true and
indeed if a true meets a false it's
going to convince him there is true in
the network if tooth will meet nothing
happens then soon enough
um all of the agents are going to
encounter a true and switch to true and
once everyone is on true this can be
mapped to an output okay it was a true
agent initially in the network great
so let me tell you uh the brief history
of discrete syrians it starts with a crn
um not a discrete Model A continuous
model
um that was used it's a mathematical
model to
um try and understand the interaction of
molecules it was uh published in a
journal in chemistry by Gillespie in
1977 and as far as I know it has nothing
to do with computer science or had
nothing to do with computer science
originally
um skip 30 years forward in 2006
population protocols were defined in a
paper by Anglo in Aspen's diamadi Fisher
and Peralta
um
they try to model maybe sensor networks
or maybe any distributed really any
distributed
Network where each agent is very weak
computationally
um and they only considered pairwise
interactions which is a bit different
from crns however for the set of states
the set of States can be of super
constant size so if you have an agents
you might as well have login
states of memory so in that sense it's a
bit different and maybe stronger
potentially from CRM so the there are
some similar similarities and some
dissimilarities between population
protocols and discrete crns eventually
discrete crns were defined in 2008 by
solovacic cook Winfrey and Brooke and
this is the model that we're going to
focus on today
let's talk about the notion of
schedulers it appears in both population
protocols and the crns
um
the idea of a scheduler is this
um today we'll focus on free agents
interactions so we need to choose free
agent teach random we we've written
before interacting agents are chosen and
then the transition function applies but
what do we mean by chosen we didn't say
how they are chosen
so um app so far there are two main
regimes one of them is the worst case
schedulers well almost we're going to uh
say two words about that and the other
regime that will be more of an interest
point for us is the uniform schedulers
so worst schedulers are a bit tricky
right because you can't go worthless all
the way I mean uh an adversary that
doesn't want anything to compute can
simply choose the same interaction over
and over again and nothing is going to
ever change
so we need to force him to uh do
something different and population
protocol they added some sort of a
sanity check that I like to think of as
a Murphy's Law so any interactions that
can be scheduled will be scheduled and
infinitely offense so in population
protocols there are the interactions are
pairwise
um so any pair is going to interact and
it's kind of it kind of makes sense
because you say well maybe the adversary
the worst case adversary is trying to
create some dissonance between two
agents so nodes that they will always
have another opportunity to check up
with one another and make sure that
they're on the same page
and this entity condition is already
enough
to allow the protocol to be able to
compute a large set of problems that are
called semi-linear sets or press
Bulgaria arithmetic we're not going to
go into that I just wanted to give you
some broad motivation and background
um however uniform schedulers are more
of an interest point for us
and for population protocols they
arrived a bit early a bit later for crns
they were there since the beginning and
basically the idea is well let's choose
the unified agents that interact a
uniformly at random and we kind of
expect the information to propagate fast
right because everything is so Random
and here you can focus on the actual
running times the number of interactions
that it takes you to get from the
initial state to the like uh the output
State the stable states that indicates
what is a final result of the
computation
and let's just say that
um maybe we should mention that
um what is the scope of running times
that we can
um deal with so there is a natural
barrier that we can't go below
um roughly and Logan interactions right
because this is the amount of
interaction by coupon collector like a
simple argument this is the amount of
interactions that we need only to see
each and every agent in the network and
if there are agents that didn't take
part in the computations and there are
inputs that weren't Incorporated uh into
computation and you can't expect
computation to
um
do something
good if it doesn't even look at the
entire input
okay
great so and look at interactions best
you can hope for
good
okay so let's talk about the free
majority
um
Dynamics
technically this is a discrete crn
protocol and the interactions are in in
triplets as we said free agent interact
in each round the set of states is only
two states X and Y and we're trying to
decide which one of them was originally
the majority this is the call of the
um of of this protocol and the
transition function is just making a
local decision a local majority between
the three nodes that the free agents
that interact currently so if the three
of them agree then they're going to stay
in their opinion if two of them has one
opinion and the third one has a
different opinion then is going to fall
back in line and uh switch to your
opinion
um
to the majority among those three so
after the interaction is done all three
agents are definitely agree with one
another
and the goal as we said before the goal
is to compute the majority of the
initial configuration so if at first we
had more access and without those of
generality usually I'm going to refer to
X as the majority
if at first we had more access then we
want
um the computation to be done with
everybody knows that X was the initial
maturity so everybody switched to X
but in actuality we're not going to be
able to compute majority
um in a general
sense we're only going to be able to
compute some relaxation of majority
which is referred to in the literature
as a proximate majority and we're going
to uh talk a little bit more into that
real soon
so let's just see uh the free majority
Dynamic connection
so our goal here is to switch all the
initial all the states the initial
majority which is X and maybe at the
beginning y gain some ground and maybe
um two wise catch an accent and and
um improve their situation but maybe X
is just talk to one another nothing
changes but you you would expect it
pretty soon um the X's are going to
catch all those wise
um alone and convince them that the XE
is indeed the majority and once everyone
are on the state X then
um
the computation is done
okay great so why approximate majority
that is the question so
um
we're going to get some inspiration from
again population protocols so so
I mean ideally we want to solve for any
input right so this this is dubbed in
the in the literature as exact majority
and doing that it's pretty hard it's
been extensively studied in population
protocols since the beginning
and we know that it's it's impossible to
do with free states
you can use four memory States and and
then it will take you roughly N squared
um rounds
um of interactions to uh
to reach your goal
um and you can't do much better in terms
of rounds of uh
um interactions but then if you want to
improve the running time if you want to
do it in N log n rounds then in fact
this is possible and it took quite a
while to to achieve this specific result
this can be done with only login state
but still a super constant number of
states so very different from four
states and N squared rounds
um as opposed to that we have login
State the super constant numbers of
memory States and we can do it in
optimal running time of analog and
running time
and this actually concluded like a
pretty long and very very original nice
uh line of works it's a paper by Dottie
if it if takari the scenic Severson
destroyac and oznetsky
okay so let's stick to our um relaxation
right so we want to solve majority but
only if the initial Gap was large enough
because if the initial Gap is just once
and this is what makes it very very
tricky and we need to have like some
invariant we need to have a lot of
states in order to really understand
like keep keep in mind even this minor
um initial advantage of the majority but
if the majority uh initially had a large
Advantage a large gap
um then it's much easier
and back in 2008
um a population protocol by Anglo in
aspenson eisenstadt already showed you
can do that in only three states which
is completely impossible for exact
majority and it will also take like an
optimal number of fronts and login
routes
so this is great we only pay in there
and the relaxation we we can only deal
with inputs that originally had a large
initial Gap
um and this protocol kind of really
really relates to a discrete crn that is
the free majority Dynamics
um
one of them has interaction in triplets
and then only two states and the other
has interaction in pairs but free state
so they added like a third stage that is
kind of neutral
um and they kind of
seem to do uh roughly the same thing
okay so what do we know about the
approximate majority so there is a nice
theorem from rather recently in a paper
by uh Condon hajiagi Kirkpatrick and
manush and it basically says the
following for the uniform scheduler
three majority Dynamics solves a
proximate majority with high probability
and within an optimal number of rounds
only provided that the initial Gap so
its number of axes excess of the number
of axes over the number of y's is at
least square root of n Times log n
so the square root of n you can think of
kind of a like a maybe
standard deviation something like that
and the login is actually there to have
a high probability of success
and it's an easy obvious observation
that if you look at worst case scheduler
for this protocol
um that's impossible right so so the
adversary can basically take if you have
even two minority agents it's enough for
the adversary to gank up with those two
over uh many many different majority
agents one at a time and convert convert
all of them to the wrong side and this
is this even with the sanity conditions
that we mentioned before this can still
hold
foreign
okay so let's just give two minutes to
um roughly understand what happens in
the analysis of this uh nice paper
um so basically they reduce the
um the entire process into a
one-dimensional random walk that keeps
track of how many axes versus how many
y's we have
um
this is one dimensional because the sum
of x's and y's is always the number of
Agents total which is n
um and they focus at each step is the
probability to convert y to an X so 2x
is converted to Y versus the probability
the two y's converted in X to Y so this
is the wrong direction because we think
of X as the majority
and basically the more X gains ground
the more of the majority nodes we have
um the bias is more towards X
and technically it's analysis is in
phases so the first phase you just want
to establish like a linear Gap and this
is the very sensitive part this is why
it doesn't work for
um X for exact majority for like uh
inputs that have like very very small
Gap because
then the probability is too high that
the minority is going to be the first to
establish a nice Gap towards their
Direction instead of the majority
Direction
the second phase is
um somewhat less sensitive in the sense
that we only want to increase this
already linear Gap to a very large
linear Gap and the tricky part in this
uh in this phase is only to it's very
delicate to really
bound to its running time so in order to
prove that the running time at large
like overall these n log n is the
optimal running time this is the phase
that is it's the most
um
it's the hardest tool to actually show
that it
keeps and again rounds and the third
phase we only want to convince all the
straggling agents all those that haven't
haven't heard the rumor yet oh okay it's
a majority was X like everybody or
almost everybody knows that but some
some few agents
um still don't know that yet so this is
um this is required in order to reach
full consensus because we said that only
the stable
configuration which is where everybody
agree on the same value this is the
configuration
that outputs okay the majority the
initial majority was actually X
okay so let's talk about uh new results
so perhaps the most important
contribution in our paper is defining an
intermediate regime some something that
goes all the way from a uniform
scheduler to a worst case scheduler and
we do so with the definition of a p
Epsilon scheduler and the game is as
follows every round the adversary cannot
choose the specific interaction but
rather a distribution over interactions
or in our case over Triplets of agents
and it can only choose distributions
that are at most of distance Epsilon
from the uniform scheduler or
distribution in LP non so p and Epsilon
are both parameters and especially we'll
be interested in L1 and L Infinity so
the one ohm and the infinity Norm
which is the maximal distance in the
um the cumulative distance between
T and the uniform distribution but in
general for any Norm that you might
consider
um when we give
when we fix Epsilon to zero actually we
get the uniform scheduler because
adversary cannot Escape that but as we
increase Epsilon we allow more freedom
to the adversary to do
all sorts of weird things and if we get
all the way to Epsilon equals 2 so this
should work for every um for every P
Norm but specifically for one Norm it's
easy to see
um basically the adversary can choose
any distribution even a Singleton
distribution like a specific interaction
and
put all the mess on this interaction so
it boils to a worst case scheduler
and we do know that for some protocols
the uniform scheduler works fine and the
worst case adverse scheduler can
basically break the whole thing so the
question is where in the middle does
that happen I mean where is this
breaking point of any protocol or many
set of protocols potentially
so in this paper specifically we study
um this regime for deformation free
majority Dynamics
and let's see what we can do with that
so we start from the uniform uh schedule
where everything works and we're trying
to increase Epsilon and see where things
might break so really what's what might
go wrong when we do that when we
disengage from the uniform distribution
and start to do things that are less and
less
um
ordered so recall the analysis uh um in
general in phases for the uniform
scheduler so if in the first phase we
only want to establish the majority and
this is kind of a sensitive part because
if we start with a small gaps and there
is a sum probability that the minority
would gain a linear advantage and we'll
go on to the wrong um to the wrong value
so
so this is a sensitive part so maybe
it's not the first place that we want to
to try and look for problems uh the
second phase is actually almost almost
Irrelevant in that sense because it
doesn't really speak of correctness the
whole analysis and the whole problematic
part in the second phase is actually
maintaining this optimal rate
um and proving that we can enlarge the
Gap from some linear Gap to a huge
linear Gap within only n log n
interactions the optimal uh the optimal
times that we can hope for uh so this
leaves us with the third phase and in
the third phase we just need to find
those last agents so straggling agents
that haven't heard the word yet that
don't know that most of the the entire
uh rest of the network already switched
to the initial majority
um
and and maybe we can focus on them and
just
um make sure that they don't hear the
news
so this is exactly what we're gonna do
as a first attempt we're just going to
try and disconnect those minority
um agents uh those minority nodes and
thus make sure that we never reach full
consensus which is the requirement for
the protocol
um so what is the cost of disconnecting
a set of nodes
so let's say that we have
most of the network already at X which
was the initial majority and we have a
set of some nodes that are still on the
value y there incorrect value and we
want to just
disconnect the set of Y nodes from the
set of X nodes
so I'll just remind you that we're
working in triplets so these are the
type of triplets that we want to
disallow triplets that have something
from the left side and something from
the right side of the network together
okay
great so for Simplicity we're just going
to talk about disconnecting a set of s
nodes where s is some integers between 1
and N over five uh you can do something
with anything between 1 and N over two
uh but for n over five it's a bit
simpler
um so let's see how much it cost us in
how much Distortion how far should we
get from the uniform this scheduler in
order to
um to be able to disconnect
a set of s nodes so for the infinity
Norm it's actually quite simple the
uniform scheduler gives each and every
Triplet a probability of exactly one
over n choose three or we denoted it by
capital N here so one over capital n and
if we allow this Distortion in L
Infinity Norm then basically we can
reduce the probability of a certain
um triplet to zero and not only for one
triplet we can do it for so many
triplets
um and in a specific order that we can
easily disconnect a single
agent from the rest of the network and
we can even disconnect a set of up to n
over five Agents from the rest of the
network without blinking it
without even blinking
however if we work in L1 you know
metric this works a little bit
differently so if we want to disconnect
more agents we're going to need to pay
some more Distortion
however we can still do pretty well
um so essentially L1 really relates to
um the statistical distance so we're
just trying to understand what is the
separating event like what is the
distinguishing event between our
scheduler it wants to disconnect those
two sides in the uniform scheduler and
this distance must be at least
the mass the the probability that the
uniform scheduler chooses something that
crosses the cut
and this probability is roughly s Over N
which is not that hard to see and not
only this is the lower bound but it's
also an upper bound so it's easy to show
that roughly s Over N Distortion in L1
distance is enough to disconnect s nodes
from the rest of the network
okay so this is the cost of this
connection
um so let's Jump Ahead to our results
and this is an informal way to um
to formulate our main theorem in this
paper so this goes for both L1 and L
Infinity first we have an impossibility
result that says the following if
Epsilon whatever P we choose either one
or Infinity if Epsilon is large enough
to disconnect agents we can prevent
consensus
basically we do the disconnection that
we just saw in the last slide and we can
make sure that we're never going to
reach full consensus
however there is an interesting
dichotomy here because if Epsilon is
slightly smaller than that for both P
equals 1 and P equals infinity
um actually we we are going to reach
consensus
um and we are going to do it with high
probability and with optimal number of
rounds the only thing that we're going
to pay is going to be the initial Gap
that we must have
so of course as Epsilon gets
closer and closer to this threshold
where you can disconnect we expect
something to to to go uh more harshly
um and actually we need uh what what we
need to fix in order to deal with that
is just to start with a slightly
slightly larger and larger Gap and when
Epsilon gets
um too large where we can actually
disconnect the agents this would
simulate
um kind of
situation where we would have wanted
to start in a consensus already and if
we've done that then we're already fine
right so this is how those two connect
to one another and yes as I said the
closer we get to this connection the
larger initial Gap is required to uh
compensate and and when Epsilon is too
large then actually we're asking for uh
this is only going to work if the
initial Gap was so large that we started
with a consensus
okay so let's see specifically for L
Infinity how those result look so a bit
more formal so we call that capital N is
going to be and choose free the number
of triplets and consider any scheduler
that is in Infinity Norm has distance of
at most Epsilon Prime over capital N
from the uniform scheduler
so the impossibility results basically
sensitive Epsilon Prime equals one this
is enough to disconnect not only a
single agent but a fifth of the network
and the protocol is definitely going to
fail because we won't be able to reach
full consensus and not even 80 percent
um of the nodes are going to agree
and however if Epsilon Prime is slightly
smaller so at most uh three quarters
then the free majority Dynamics is going
to solve approximate majority it's going
to do so with high probability and
within an optimal number of rounds
um or order of n log n
and this is provided that the initial
Gap was well the initial Gap that we
need even for the uniform distribution
for the uniform scheduler so at least
some um
um at least
some
um deviation plus some factor that only
depends on Epsilon Prime and N so if
Epsilon Prime is constant then we're
going to have to start with a linear Gap
in order to guarantee that we reach
consensus but if Epsilon Prime is
smaller than a constant
um if Epsilon Prime is say order of 1
over square root of n then this is the
dominant Factor so we get the exact same
result that we got for the uniform
scheduler even for scheduler that
deviate from the uniform scheduler in
all sorts of ways
and just to put it in a picture so we
have this uh range of Epsilon Prime and
here it goes from I am sorry of Epsilon
not the normalized Epsilon Prime
um but the distance from uniform in L
Infinity so one is already the worst
case
scheduler
and zero is of course it's a uniform
scheduler
and basically uh in one over n capital n
and this is where we kind of see the
threshold and below this we are going to
get optimal time as long as we have a
large enough Gap and above that actually
we can disconnect the network and
prevent converges
um I will show you the same results for
L1 but those are a bit more involved and
interesting uh there's an interplay
between the Gap
um and how much of a consensus we want
to read so we allow ourselves not to
reach full contents but only a constant
uh fraction of consensus and it goes
into uh the formal statement of the
result so I'm not going to
um put it here you can find it in the
paper
um but I do want to show you that in L1
things are more complicated
in both sides of the equation so also in
the lower bound side there are more
interesting things that can be said in
L1 rather than in L infinity and
actually the first phase which we said
is like very delicate and and
um
should be dealt with later on
um the first phase actually can go wrong
so let's see how we can do that um under
an L1 distorted scheduler so what we're
going to do is refer to the some Network
as a set of three agents and then we're
going to add two agents that we're going
to call persistent and so those agents
are going to initially start with the
minority value
right so those those agents are going to
kind of flip the script and what we'll
do is uh
um we'll Define the
next uh the following scheduler which is
a one two Epsilon so scheduler
sorry which is a one two Epsilon
scheduler
and basically the scheduler is going to
do the following with probability
Epsilon it's going to choose
um one random free node so some some
specific node here and the two
persistent nodes
and with probability one minus Epsilon
is going to do what we're used to which
is choosing um free
so three nodes that are free
um and interact among them
so a different way to see this entire
thing
a different way to see it is that
perhaps
perhaps the actual Network that we have
is those of the free agents
and basically with probability one minus
Epsilon we do everything fine we use the
uniform scheduler over those uh this set
of uh like free agents blue and uh
brownish in the picture but with
probability Epsilon we basically choose
a free agent
and two persistent agents so it's like
choosing a free agent no matter its
color and just switching its state to y
so if those three are chosen then this x
is going to become y
and if
those we are chosen
then the Y is going to stick so whoever
is chosen with the two persistent nodes
are agents I'm sorry is going to switch
to Y immediately and this gives us kind
of an Epsilon weight
for the probability that will con that
we're going to convert X to Y
um and not y to X so in some sense we
managed to push all the Distortion of
the schedule or the absolute Distortion
of the scheduler towards the wrong
direction the direction of the
converting a majority node X to a
minority node Y and not vice versa
um and specifically
we can see a dichotomy for this
scheduler uh that if the initial
if the initial Gap is at least 10 times
Epsilon n right so it's large enough in
favor of X then this Epsilon uh then
this Epsilon Distortion is not going to
overcome this Gap and the three nodes
are going to convert to X of course the
two persistent dots are going to stick
to Y but all the three nodes are going
to converge to X
however
if the initial if the initial Gap was
too small so smaller than Epsilon and
say epsilon n over 10 something that is
significantly smaller than this Epsilon
sorry so this Epsilon probability
um
then this Epsilon probability to
suddenly create a y actually becomes
um quite significant and we're going to
see on the first phase we're going to
see a shift towards y towards the
minority and Y is going to be the first
one to gain a linear advantage and from
there on phase two and phase 3 Y is
basically going to overtake the entire
network
um
so this is everything that I wanted
um to show you
um let's just summarize
okay great so to summarize in this talk
we defined the P Epsilon schedulers
which is kind of an interpolation
between uniform schedulers and the worst
case schedulers
um we exemplified this notion in the
free majority Dynamics and we have seen
that small Distortion is already enough
to allow disconnections and therefore
break the free majority Dynamics or at
least your original way that it is
defined
with slightly smaller distortions
however and everything seems to still
work so we do have some sort of
dichotomy kind of the threshold where
you can
when you can disconnect nodes is exactly
the amount that is required to break
something and if you have less
Distortion that you are able to play
with as the adversary you cannot
actually break the protocol and the
protocol is going to follow through and
compute the
approximate majority
and in the paper of course we also have
full proofs of all these claims and not
only hand wavings
um and we're discussing other Norms such
as a every Pinon basically sandwich
between say one ohm and say infinity
Norm in some sense using holder
inequality on the one side and the
trivial inequality on the other side and
we also have some other lower bounds
um and some of them are interestingly
some of them interestingly have even
expansion properties so one might claim
that the uniform scheduler is such a
great expander and if we disconnect the
network then we're the worst expander
ever so maybe expansion is is the key
property so no actually this example
here uh has great expansion
um and another example in the paper as
well
so I'll leave you at that and
please
um contact us
any one of the authors if you have any
question or if you're interested in the
paper at all and I encourage you to go
and read the full paper
um
thank you